i'm wes larson a wildlife biologist and
lover of the outdoors for as long as i
can remember
i'm traveling the country to find the
next generation of conservationists the
people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet and protect the
animals we share it with
my first stop takes me all the way down
to the southern wilds of florida also
known as the everglades
they're huge hot and home to one of the
fiercest predators on the planet the
american alligator
researchers from the university of
florida have taken me deep into the
swamp to survey the local gator
population
oh we gotta get him cool
wow gosh
i just got to say
like ever since i was a kid i fantasized
about coming to florida and meeting
alligators up close
alligators are at the top of the food
chain crucial to maintaining the
ecological balance of the everglades
but despite this dominance alligators
are under threat from a foreign invader
that no one saw coming the argentine
black and white tegu
facing that threat head on are uf
researchers jenna cole and sarah cook
[Music]
how's it going hey what's up i'm wes and
jenna nice to meet you
[Music]
so we are out here looking for invasive
reptiles so we're gonna be looking for
the argentine black and white tegu
they're just a huge problem preying on
our native species tegu populations have
exploded in recent years so jenna and
sarah are painstakingly trapping and
removing them one by one
so how many traps are we going to be
checking so we've got 160 traps out here
a long way yeah so i mean it's a pretty
extensive trap line 160 traps spread
over miles of uninhabited marshland
where do you even begin
well you start at trap number one
so our first trap of the day yep this
will be the first one and it looks like
we've got something oh cool
that is so crazy yeah he's biting at the
trap
kind of a scary little predator like a
little dinosaur yeah they essentially
they are little dinosaurs uh-huh and all
you had in this trap to bait him in was
a chicken yep just a single chicken egg
so if you could imagine a whole nest of
alligator eggs
[Music]
i mean it just looks like a little egg
eater
but it's not only alligators that are at
risk
pegus will eat just about anything
the ground nesting birds the turtles
snakes all those animals are potential
prey for these large lizards
a single tegu can consume an entire nest
of eggs in one sitting so we don't take
any chances it's straight into the bag
for removal
so i'm bagging my first tegu here
there we go you got it
up and up and down like up and down yes
there we go
voila
cool
one down all right let's catch 160 more
right
we have to be very conscious of where
we're holding the bag because they can
actually bite you through the bag
you've been bit through the bag
okay yeah you also have to watch if you
set the bag down they can run away in
the back yes so if you ever have to sit
down the ground we'll step on the bag
while we're doing whatever oh yeah the
bag just hops
that's crazy
the farther we go the more apparent it
is just how many tegus are crawling
around out here
another one down he's excited
we've got another one guys
[Music]
oh we got another one awesome grumpy one
yeah i can't believe how many there are
out here there's a ton there is a whole
burning population of them saving the
everglades one tegu at a time
[Music]
this is the end of the line for these
tagus each one that jenna and her team
captures is brought back to the lab and
euthanized and that's tough for a
reptile lover like jenna you really have
to look at a big picture i like tagues
and it's unfortunate that there is no
alternative but it's not just that we're
removing them and that's it we are using
them to learn more about the species so
that we can mitigate and prevent them
from causing more terrible damage than
what's what's going on already
yeah that's not a small one huh no he's
not a small one a couple hundred yards
from where we just caught a tegu in this
little canal there's a pretty big
alligator just kind of hanging out so it
shows that they really aren't occupying
the same space it's not impossible to
imagine a nest around oh he's coming up
oh he's yeah wow
we caught a number of tagues today out
here they're from argentina originally
so how did they get to florida the
general consensus on how the tegus got
here is through the pet trade they were
either released or escaped into the
ecosystem they're very small and very
cute when they are first sold and first
hatched and as they grow people tend to
realize that they may be in for a lot
more than they bargained for
and then in the middle of the swamp we
come across one very special tegu
so we've got a tegu here that has a
transmitter on it so i believe that
means that we actually get to pull him
out after we bag him and i actually get
to get my hands on him that's right
right yep go ahead and get them out in
this vast wilderness the research team
has transmitters on only six tegus so
it's a real stroke of luck that we found
this one
what do you think wes
pretty cool
when they squirm you don't grab the tail
yeah
and that's just because it can detach
yeah he'll drop it
i can definitely tell there's some real
strength
we've obviously got a tegu out of the
trap that we're handling so why is it
that we're able to pull this one out we
are actually following him around
and learning more about where he lives
and what he's doing out here so that we
can learn more ways to effectively trap
and remove them from this everglades
system he's like a little spy for you
guys yeah okay so he's like a double
agent
it's hard to believe that something as
small as releasing some pet lizards can
threaten the health of an entire
ecosystem
my time here has proven to me just how
delicate that balance can be
the scientists we met from uf are
fighting a daily battle to right some of
our wrongs it's hot humid and
frustrating work but these biologists
care deeply about native species and
tagging along helped me understand just
how important their battle is
[Music]
today i'm headed into the desert due
west of salt lake city
i'm on my way to a remote research
station in the ghost chute mountains of
nevada
you can just barely start to see the
ghost shoots out there in the distance
so remote in fact that researchers spend
months at a time on site
you have to be an especially hardcore
conservationist to sign up for this job
hey man
mr west you must be jesse yeah man nice
to meet you good to meet you too you
ready to see some hawks i am
jesse watson is a research biologist
with hawkwatch this is his second season
on the mountain but he's been working
with birds since he was a kid this is a
long-term raptor monitoring site we've
been counting and catching hawks here
since the early 80s so about 35 years
we're gonna hike all the way up to 9000
feet yeah man all the way to the top
there are no roads to the camp supplies
are flown in by helicopter carried up on
your back
it starts getting fairly
fairly steep in this next section a lot
of switchbacks but it's worth it for
these birds raptors are kind of a
barometer for
the ecosystem they're at the top of the
food chain and so if they're not doing
well then there's an indication that
something is wrong
the hawk watch researchers live full
time on the mountain counting hawks by
day
and sleeping in tents at night
welcome to camp and uh where's the hot
tub yeah
for hawk watch to study these birds up
close they have to catch them first
and here's where an unexpected member of
the team comes into play so raptors are
migrating along the ridge they're hungry
so we use pigeons
as part of our team to help us capture
them and i notice you've got these
harnesses for your pigeons just to make
sure that you know if the hawk comes in
it's not actually going to hurt it
absolutely i mean they're pretty
critical member of our our team and we
definitely treat them with utmost
respect
[Music]
with our pigeon safely in place we
settle into the trapping blind and meet
scott one of hawk watch's veteran crew
leaders
so how are we doing scott how's the
flight good really good it's actually
pushing our biggest day there's a lot of
birds throwing up out there and before
we knew it
got him
you're just wondering what's going on
right now huh
so yeah we've been in this blind like i
don't know five minutes we already
caught a cooper's hawk
catching the birds doesn't hurt them in
any way
okay sweetie there you go
right in the can
i see you're being very delicate with
those talons as you pull it out yeah so
the thing you really gotta watch with
raptors is their their feet and their
bill are the two things that can really
tear you up and in just a couple of
minutes each bird is given a checkup and
a tracking band
she's banded she's banded she got
jewelry it's so crazy to me how calm she
is that she's in this little tube
like she's not chirping she's not
struggling she's just totally relaxed so
those are the main body measurements
weight wing cord and standard tail yeah
the go shoot mountains are a kind of
super highway for migrating raptors and
over just a couple of hours we banded
seven different birds overall at this
site hawkwatch researchers have assessed
and banded over 65 000 different raptors
yeah so the next step is basically
releasing her
so this one's ready to go we banded her
she is definitely ready
just the way they like look at you it's
just so intense like it's like they're
just looking straight through you almost
ready hi
[Music]
there she goes
pretty cool
i bet you don't get tired of that no
never gets old yeah definitely not there
she is right there yeah
while catching and banding is crucial
for assessing individual birds the
status of raptor populations is what
jesse cares about most so the bulk of
the team's work looks like this
[Music]
during migration season in the fall the
researchers are out here every single
day literally counting each bird that
flies by
through the years they've counted over
13 million
one by one
you want to kind of start below horizon
and just kind of scan up slowly
and if i see a bird i just yell it out
yeah cool
[Music]
counting birds can be tedious it means
watching the skies for hours
so what's that one down there oh yeah
right over the ridge
oh yeah that's an adult red tail so
wet's got a bird down here
just going down low
the counting itself is the most
important thing that we do year after
year after year we can get those trends
so we can see like hey
these numbers are going up or they're
going down we've seen declines in
species like golden eagles and american
kestrels on migration through these
counts the idea that i'm getting is that
if you guys weren't up here
on this ridge in the cold in the wind
for months at a time all day long
counting these birds
like no one would really have any idea
what the numbers are doing absolutely
yeah it's a real dedicated effort you
really have to commend our crews that
are counting and doing the work
when you work in conservation you
sometimes forget that when people see
the studies they don't see the hard work
meticulous data collection and luck that
you need to get the results
standing on this mountain seeing
hawkwatch's efforts firsthand is a great
reminder of the real tangible work that
goes into this kind of conservation
[Applause]
this time around i'm on the west coast
just north of monterey bay i'm meeting
up with an elephant seal research team
at the university of california santa
cruz hey hey good morning good morning
nice to see you we've got a busy day
ahead so if you could grab one of these
jackets and then we will head up to the
beach
rachel holzer has been studying elephant
seals at the costa lab for four years
and believes tracking elephant seals
could hold the key to a deeper
understanding of the ocean as a whole
our mission this morning is to attach
some high-tech tracking tags to an
elephant seal but not just any seal will
do we are a little bit particular about
the animals we put satellite tags on so
an adult female over four years old and
under 13 years old hasn't been tracked
before
and has been on the beach for nearly a
month
in short they're looking for a seal that
has had her pup and is ready to head
back out into the sea rachel tells me
that there are seven promising
candidates on the beach today which
sounds like a lot to me
but then i see the colony for the first
time
we just kind of rounded this hill and
suddenly all these seals are spread out
in front of us one thing that's super
surprising is the amount of localization
that's going on all the seals kind of
talking to each other out here
it's a lot to take in the seals are big
loud and absolutely cover the beach take
binos take a recite data book for sure
and yeah we'll see what we can find the
researchers are fanning out they're just
going seal the seal trying to find the
particular female that they're trying to
tag today with a couple thousand seals
on the beach it's like looking for a
needle in a very noisy and potentially
dangerous haystack
but it's worth the risk turns out if you
want to study the farthest reaches of
the ocean elephant seals are natural
deep sea explorers they go way out into
the middle of the north pacific and they
dive far deeper than anybody thought was
possible
and eventually rachel spots the perfect
seal if you're looking straight down
there's two animals back to back one has
a pep nursing on her right side i think
that that is her
we had a good look at her so we're
estimating her mass at about 340
kilograms so we're gonna pull up a 3.4
cc dose of telazole and so you
physically just go up and put the needle
in them yep that is
how this goes it's a big needle it's to
get through all that blubber yeah
exactly
there's a big male over there it's
actually the alpha male of this colony
so we're kind of just waiting for them
to get positioned in a way to where the
researchers can go in sedate the seal
and then attach their tag
this is the most dangerous part of the
research rachel has to inject the
sedative by hand and elephant seals can
be
unpredictable they are very dangerous
animals i know they look pretty lazy and
sleepy if they're on a beach but they
can move surprisingly quickly and react
surprisingly quickly and the big guys
you know the males are almost two tons
and they can run as fast as a person can
run
[Music]
we spend years being trained to work
with them properly
[Music]
[Applause]
did you get the seal stuck yes we did
[Music]
oh
just keep a light hand on her nose just
in case she she pulls that again
there's like a bunch of different things
going on right now it's pretty
impressive
teresa's taking these ultrasound
measurements with the blubber
these two collaborators are putting on
the epoxy for this
tag that we're attaching to get that
oceanographic data
and then on top we're also attaching a
bhf tag
rachel's kind of organizing everyone and
directing everyone to do what they're
doing grab another popsicle stick
meanwhile as always we have all these
other seals that we kind of always have
to be keeping an eye on to make sure
that no one's coming up and
aggressively kind of challenging the
group
thank you patrick
we've been monitoring the population at
any nuevo for between three and four
decades now if the elephant seals are
not doing well that means that something
is really going sideways down in the
food web we got another seal kind of
creeping back here
all right
so yeah one of the really cool things
about these tags
is they're actually recording
oceanographic information with them all
sorts of things that they would normally
record with like a really expensive
research vessel they're using these
seals kind of as that research vessel
and elephant seals make exceptionally
good research vessels
after they leave the colony they swim
out into the pacific for thousands of
miles diving over a mile below the
surface
and all the while the tags will be
collecting data what you end up with is
a three-dimensional profile of the ocean
that is if all goes as planned
it's just so crazy to have like this
happening 20 feet away 10 feet away as
we're working on the seal
at times it reminded me of being in an
cat era others it was like being on
another planet surrounded by hostile
aliens
one thing that's really interesting is
this kind of like matador act that they
have going on it's just a tarp i mean if
the
but through the chaos the team gets it
done deploying three different tags and
giving the seal a full checkup all right
you guys can go ahead and roll her
on teresa's cow
okay go ahead
[Music]
good breath go ahead and pull it so far
so good
with the science complete there's one
important step left
waiting for our seal to wake up we'll
stay nearby
so that if a male decides to try and
mate with her we can prevent it we're
fully responsible for the well-being of
the animal until she is
capable of taking care of herself
so it looks like our female's doing
really well she's recovering nicely
she's moved back into the group and
hopefully in about three days she'll
head off to see and give us lots of
awesome data
looking out at the colony it's hard to
imagine that a hundred years ago
elephant seals nearly disappeared
they did almost go extinct back in the
early 1900s
once the seal was protected and hunting
was no longer permitted they rebounded
and they have been spreading ever since
and now you guys are using them in all
these kind of new novel ways to like
learn more about the ocean to protect
other species yeah absolutely
i found that conservation success can
sometimes be as simple as changing
perceptions
rachel and her team have shown that an
animal that appears to just lie around
on a beach is actually an incredible
traveler and athlete and by harnessing
their power we are able to gain a deeper
understanding of the ocean
it makes me wonder how else we could be
working with wildlife to protect the
planet that we all share